Film Courage: Something you said triggered
a question I have further down on my list
but I’ll bump it up and that was you were
referring to the music video of the film which
you made while you were in law school and
then I watched a video where you say when
a book turns into a film, then a game and
then a comic book, that’s not transmedia,
it’s multimedia.
So can we discuss how many people think that
this is transmedia and dispel some of the
myths?
Houston Howard: Yeah.
So especially in the 1980’s we had this
boom of the multimedia franchise.
And multimedia is the same story that is adapted
across multiple mediums.
You know, the book becomes the movie, that
movies become the graphic novel, that graphic
novel becomes the video game.
It’s basically the same story and the same
plot over and over and over again, just expressed
through multiple mediums.
Transmedia is sort of this second cousin of
that and where instead of having the TWILIGHT
book become the TWILIGHT movie that becomes
the TWILIGHT video game that becomes the TWILIGHT
graphic novel.
Now we have the books that then set up the
movie that then leads into the graphic novel
that then culminates in the video game all
the different touch points tell a completely
different story but in a way where all the
stories work together to tell one big story.
That’s a different process but it was birthed
out of the necessity of the marketplace.
Having grown up in the 1980’s and the 1990’s,
the multimedia franchise was fine because
what else are you going to do?
We didn’t have the 8,000 different entertainment
options that we have today.
It was very limited.
And so consumers and audiences were okay with
just experiencing the same story over and
over and over again because there were very
limited amounts of options.
Today, we now have 8,000 television channels,
we have cable, satellite, network, Netflix,
Hulu, Amazon.
We have millions of Youtube videos.
We have access to every TV show ever made,
every movie ever made, every book ever written.
We have millions of mobile games that are
available in our pocket anytime we want.
And so now when we can entertain ourselves
with anything that we want, the marketplace
has been going for new stuff rather than repurpose
content.
So if you give a consumer the option of a
video game where you already know the story
and a video game where you don’t know the
story, now they’re opting for the new story.
They’re opting for the new book.
They’re opting for the new movie because
they just don’t want to repurpose the same
thing over and over and over again.
So when audiences demand new, new, new, you
have to figure out how to continually give
them a new story rather than repurpose story
which then has created this really interesting
opportunity in the marketplace but at the
same time, obstacle in the marketplace because
now we have to figure out how to continually
tell new stories because the multimedia franchise
just isn’t performing the way that it used
to perform.
And so just like any good capitalistic system,
the market is the one that pushes toward change
and that’s what we’ve seen over the past
ten years.